why what your gripe is what is your
gripe with infinity and it's not just
the real number it's not just card
it's all infinities
even the countable infinities yeah so i
would say that um
my my main reservation
probably is in the direction of
assuming that what can do an infinite
number of things
so um i think it's worthwhile to point
out you know this classical
dichotomy between an ongoing infinity
and a completed infinity that was
already the subject of of thought in
aristotle's day
and the ancient greeks had uh had a view
that uh you know an unbounded infinity
was like a like in euclid you know
there's a euclid draws lines but the
hymn lines can be extended that's one of
his sort of axioms or assumptions you
can always extend a line
but it's not an infinite object to begin
with in fact at any particular point is
always a finite object
but it's a finite object that can be
extended
in a similar way you know we can talk
about the natural numbers and we can
count you know from one up to a certain
amount and recognize that we could at
least potentially carry on that counting
but at any given time we are always sort
of only in a possession with only a
range of possible um you know actual
numbers perhaps constrained by
by our computers our memories or perhaps
even more strongly constrained by the
the size of the universe and
and and perhaps limits that the compute
that the you know the computational
power of the universe imposes on
on on numbers and possibilities for
numbers
so so if we have this distinction then
um i think what what characterizes
modern say 20th century approaches to
infinity is is this idea that we can
capture
the the completed infinity
and that we can give that a name and we
can treat it as an object ah which which
is then a a prior uh a prior object that
we can then use for further for further
constructions and such
there's this long standing respect for
the for the you know ongoing aspect
infinity the fact that you know it goes
beyond our view and at some point we
were no longer able to deal with it that
has been lost and we've replaced that
with a a kind of a
an arrogance in my view um that that we
can do something which in fact we can't
do
so at the heart of my objection i guess
is is this implicit belief that
people have that they can
they can do something that they actually
demonstrably cannot do
and you know and whether it be
working with
infinite decimals working with dedicant
cots working with koshi sequences of
rationals or whatever framework for the
real numbers would be or whether it's
involving infinite sets which are the
basis of manifolds or perhaps varieties
or topological vector spaces right
in in all these cases we're kind of
assuming that we have this this
collection of objects that we actually
have it's right in front of us
and that we can uh we can then use it to
manipulate it in in other ways so
i think what we need to do is
adopt a more
modest and and sober
position
and and recognize
what it is that we can and we can't do
we should try to restrict ourselves in
my view to things that that we can do
and a good litmus test for that is can
we get our computer
to
encode to embody these notions that
we're that we're trying to work with
you know so it's not a philosophical
discussion uh particularly where you
know i i i create uh you know pleasant
arguments and you create pleasant
arguments you know it's rather
can the computer
support
the objects that you're that you're
talking about
or that you're wanting to talk about
i've heard you say before in a few
different interviews
that it's not real unless you can write
it down now i think you're amending that
and what you mean is it's not real
unless you can program a computer to do
it because we can write down real
analysis with infinities so i'm assuming
when you say write it down you have a
specific meaning of write it down well
actually i don't know if we can i mean
what we can do is and what we often do
is we write down symbols for things
you know and and and we identify in our
mind like we write down this this uh
this r this r you know this uh double
barred r and say okay there's the real
numbers um but of course that's not
really the real numbers that's just a
symbol for it and in fact we have the
symbols for a whole variety of things
including
constants including the function values
and such which
actually we have a hard time actually
uh really writing down in any meaningful
way and and in a completely parallel way
we have a hard time encoding on our
computers
are you of the mind that
underlying reality is something like an
algorithmic process that at its
core nature's computational much like
i'm sure you've heard wolfram talk about
uh
yeah no i don't have that that opinion
i'm not saying that's not not a good
opinion and it very well may end up
being uh
jury uh very close to what's what's
happening so i think we have to
certainly uh embrace that as a
possibility you know um but i feel as if
we're not close enough to the bottom yet
to to really have a good sense of what's
going on um you know i we we still have
to get these submersibles down further
and deeper and and in more
thorough way before we can really start
making um i think confident assessments
about what's really going on
but i i do
believe that the algorithmic or
computational approach to mathematics is
is a solid one from a logical point of
view
that it gives us
a surety
that uh transcends
arguments just with phrases and words
and an english language
it's a kind of a litmus test for whether
we're
on the right track or not
when a physics student first encounters
infinity as an object
well let's forget about the real numbers
it it's usually from an investigation
into spinners and then penrose has
the riemann sphere and says well okay
the top point of the riemann sphere
let's call that infinity and then we
give it some algebraic properties that
we imagine infinity may have so if you
plus infinity with another constant it
would equal infinity so i assume you
have an objection to that or maybe you
have an objection far before because
it's a sphere which is a continuous
entity so you're like well i object even
far before that level
um well you know i i don't uh object to
um
you know the the
the riemann sphere utilizes
stereographic projection to uh you think
of the equatorial plane as being sort of
a copy of the complex numbers and you
can then stereograph
uh plea project from the north north
pole so you can sort of wrap the
the the plane or the complex numbers
onto the onto the sphere with the
exception of this north pole and
and then as you go far out on the
complex number plane then you're
approaching this north pole so it makes
sense to say okay well we have a new
point here we should give it a name why
don't we call it something so we could
call it alef or or zeta or infinity so i
have no problem at all with someone
saying well let's use this particular
symbol the lemna skate symbol and call
it infinity
so that's that's not an example of um
of assuming that you can do an infinite
number of things
which is which is ultimately my my
serious objection that that that you're
believing that you can do something
which you actually can't in the case of
the sphere you can do the stereographic
rejection it's all algebraic you can
make it all algebraic and so it's
completely well defined and i have no
problems with that so in classical
geometry for example in projective
geometry projective geometry uh uses
points at infinity so called you know in
in a in a very important and integral
way
and in the uh 17th and 18th centuries
these points at infinity had something
of a mystical aspect
and and people didn't really know you
know what what what does it mean to to
have a point at infinity like it's like
the horizon it's infinitely far away etc
but in the 19th century people people
realized that you could you could
rethink this in in terms of affine
geometry in one dimension up
so you could understand the projective
plane by
embedding it in a certain way in
three-dimensional affine space
and so and then that
completely demystified the the role of
infinity so the infinity then just
becomes
those points who's whose third
coordinate is zero as opposed to the
other ones which are have third chord at
one so it becomes completely uh
uh
reasonable and and all the mystery
vanishes
you know so
so that that's that that's i think a
good thing to keep in mind it it's
um
whether the crucial the crucial thing is
are you
assuming that you're able to do an
infinite number of things and and get a
completed result which you're then
then using for further uh constructions
let's drill down into this notion of do
like we can't do the infinity so
specifically what's meant when you say
we cannot do it
well i think maybe it would be good at
this point if if i could sort of
demonstrate some things in a little bit
of a hands-on way because i sort of like
to be explicit
and maybe that would be a benefit to
your um
to your viewers and listeners can you
see this
yes
i've spelt your name correctly i hope
good good okay so this is a little
program it's called scientific workplace
uh it's it's quite convenient it's what
i used to to write papers with but it's
also has some mathematical computational
power so that i'm quite familiar with so
i can use it to illustrate things
great so let me just start by just uh
showing you a few things first of all
just to impress you with the power of
this um sure
this uh this program okay so here here's
a number okay which i'm just randomly
making and i'm going to ask it to um to
factor this
okay so what you see here is the prime
factorization of this number
okay so that that's good um if i want to
do arithmetic like let's say i want to
do
eight no i have to go into math mode
okay eight
to the eight
plus
seven
to the seven okay so there's there's
some potential arithmetic if i evaluate
that i get uh some number like this
if i if i make this 8 into 18 let's say
in this into 17 i can evaluate again i'm
going to get some some bigger number so
we we have the potential of doing
arithmetic here but
one of the things that i think people
perhaps don't appreciate is that
our ability to do arithmetic smoothly
diminishes it diminishes
quite steadily as the numbers get big
and
you know a lot of talk about infinity
and the problems of infinity are a
little bit of a red herring because
actually uh
the
essential
problems actually manifest themselves
long before you get to infinity
they manifest themselves already when
you start dealing with bigger and bigger
numbers
so for example if let's say i i replace
this 8
with an 8 to the 8 and this
so now i'm talking about
you know this thing here
so if i was due to do this i i'm not
sure if i really want to do this um but
okay let me just try okay so this is
what's going to happen my computer is
going to uh sit here for um and i don't
know how long you know
maybe some some years okay
yeah
now it it has realized that this is his
way
okay
okay
so um
okay and editors told me okay this is
this is silly you're not able to do this
now
so when we when we do a lot of um
calculations in in in mathematics
we're
we're not taking this
crucial aspect of reality of
computational reality uh sufficiently
you know uh seriously
so let's say for example that um
i want to calculate exponential function
of 7. so i want e to the 7. so what what
is that
so i could evaluate it numerically i'm
getting this this number here so what is
actually e to the to the 7 well
you will know of course that this thing
has a power series expansion and i can
just remind people what that is by going
to power series
okay
so here here is the power series
expansion for e to the x and most
functions that physicists deal with in
fact that mathematicians deal with are
all
sort of something similar like this that
they can ultimately be reduced to to
series
which which carry on okay they're
they're ongoing
and the the arithmetic with such things
is very parallel to arithmetic with
polynomials polynomials are just sort of
the finite uh versions of this where you
truncate and and do the arithmetic and
then you get a finite polynomial
so
what we're really doing when we
calculate e to the seven is we're we're
supposing that we're going to replace
this x here with with seven and we're
going to calculate all these terms and
we're going to um you know see see what
what we get
but so this is this is a key example of
a calculation that actually we cannot do
in its entirety
so you you cannot
you cannot uh
look at this this sum
uh going to infinity
um and and calculate the entire thing
what what you can do is you can truncate
it like like what right the program is
doing right here okay so like this is
what what your calculator you will do
your calculator will dispense with all
the terms past some point and just use
this finite polynomial to calculate e to
the seven
but with with this understanding that
there's there's some uh some some
inaccuracy or some some error because
we've we've truncated things and just
as a note to the audience that term you
erased is a stand-in for an infinite
sequence of additions
that's right that's right yeah so this
series ostensibly carries on to infinity
okay uh with the coefficients that that
are in front here getting uh
increasingly big in the denominators and
these powers are getting increasingly
large
um and and when we calculate e to the
seven we're thinking about you know
adding up all of these things so we
could we could talk about you know the
difficulty in in doing this to infinity
but before we get to that difficulty we
we get to the difficulty of getting to
the range where we're talking about
numbers even of this size
so in other words if i take this sum
okay um
let me write it out as a sum so if i
take the sum from k equals whoops
k equals zero
two okay let me uh put in here uh
10
to the 10
to the 10. okay of and what are we
summing we're summing a 1 over
k factorial
and times x to the
k
okay so that's that's not e to the x
but that's
like the first 10 to the 10 terms of e
to the x
okay
so we have not gone to infinity but we
have gone a long long ways
and already at this stage we are talking
about something that doesn't make sense
computationally on our computers and and
more crucially we're talking about
something which does not make sense in
the universe as as we as we are in
in other words this number here already
even though it's relatively modest by
big number standards is already
ensuring that that this this computation
will overwhelm the computational aspects
of the entire universe
uh in fact uh to be completely confident
about that statement if i go to um one
more
okay now i can be completely confident
i've got a
10 to the 10 to the 10 to the 10. so
that that that's that sum is going to be
completely overwhelming the the
computational capacity of the universe
even if we use the entire universe and
even if we write at the planck scale
sure
so
so here you see there's this fundamental
problem that we we cannot calculate
this initial sum
so in
to be honest we have no right to assert
the
the existence or or say anything really
much about uh
some which is vastly superior vastly
bigger than this one namely going to
infinity so this is very disconcerting
to uh to a modern analyst they don't
want to think this way because
this means that
the the exactness that they currently
ascribe to something like the
exponential function or or the cosine or
the sine or the tan or the arctan or
one of hundreds of other such similar
things
that exactness is is illusory and that
it's uh more a game that we're playing
that's not really computationally
valid so we would we would like the
exponential
function to be a function in the sense
that it inputs a real number and outputs
a real number
but the reality is that's not what
happens i know you mentioned that this
is not a philosophical statement but to
me it sounds philosophical and
underneath it has a practical nature to
it that we practically cannot calculate
this and then it also has the term
existence or real this is not real now
just for those who are listening i know
we use the terms real number we
shouldn't use the word real number
because it muddies the waters so you're
saying that this
is not real because you can't input
and get an output in the universe
so is it a practical claim i'm trying to
understand what the objection is it's a
practical objection or it's an
in-principle objection so it it's really
ultimately a question not of of
existence but of definition
i mean i know often we phrase these
questions in terms of existence like
does infinity exist or does e to the
seven exist et cetera but a prior and
and usually more profound question is
you know what is the definition of
infinity or e to the seven that's what
you once should think about first
so um
what i'm saying is that the definition
of e to the seven is not it's not a
valid definition let me see if i'm
understanding it correctly so you're
saying it's not valid because inside e
to the any number is an infinite amount
of steps we cannot do an infinite amount
of steps therefore the definition it
fails at the definitional level
that's right that's right we cannot get
to the end of the rainbow so for us to
say let let g be the pot of gold at the
end of the rainbow is is is not a proper
definition
now what if someone says like a child
says or a first-year student which at
least i was a child when i was like
childlike and naive like what if they
say okay forget about whether or not e
to the 10 to the 10 to the 10 exists and
think of it as well if we treat this
as if it exists then it allows us some
simplicity in other calculations so for
example i have a circle here
this diffuser right here and i have a
circle if i treat it mathematically like
an actual circle it simplifies
calculations for me whether or not it is
a circle or whether or not a circle
exists
that's another question so what if i use
it almost like an architect uses design
so i use this i know the final building
won't look like this but hey for my
purposes it's fine so what are your
objections to that
first of all your your choice of a
circle is a very very good one because
the the circle actually is at the heart
of a lot of these difficult issues even
historically going back to the origins
of trigonometry with the uh the
astronomers the greek astronomers and
hindu astronomers and so on
um
the the need for uh for essentially trig
tables that that related uh angles to x
and y coordinates essentially um i mean
these these
the people who created these tables
realize that you could not
create exact values that this was
necessarily an approximate story
and that that approximate aspect has
permitted
almost not all but almost all
trigonometric tables since ancient times
and so there's a distinction i think a
really important distinction here
between things which are intrinsically
approximate and things which are
intrinsically exact
and i suppose one way of
thinking about my objection is that i
want to make very clear the distinction
in our minds between
being on the exact side of the fence and
being on the approximate side of the
fence
okay
and i think
yes it that does complicate things in in
the sense that whenever you
uh add distinctions on into a theory it
will typically complicate the theory but
it also makes it more
accurate and representative of reality
in mathematics most
most applied mathematicians first of all
mathematics has been largely applied
mathematics for for most of its history
i think perhaps we should we should say
that
um a lot of the great mathematicians you
know were essentially applied
mathematicians they were interested in
concrete problems and solving solving
real life problems and they they
recognized that a lot of the techniques
that they had were sort of operating in
this
approximate space
you know where
like like sine and cosine you don't you
don't know exactly what the sine or
cosine of some particular angle is but
you you know it's two three or four
decimal places because you have tables
and that's good enough to solve whatever
problem that you're working on
this this is i think a really important
distinction and you could characterize
mathematics pure mathematicians desire
for real numbers
okay and and we said we were going to
maybe stick to infinity but but to be to
be honest it's really the real number
question which is really at the heart of
this this discussion okay the the real
critical um issue is
what's
what's the correct arithmetic
of of the continuum
because that's the basis for for for
modern geometry that's the basis for for
analysis
see historically the the role of
infinity has been a supporting role um
infinity arose with cantor and and uh
promoted by dedicant as a supportive
structure to frame a theory of real
numbers
this is sort of how the story goes and
this is essentially why it's so
important for analysts to
to you know play along with with modern
set theory because they they see that as
a buttress for
the the theory of real numbers
but
the
the problem with with real number
arithmetic which i point out uh in a lot
of places is that this
this lack of being able to actually
perform calculations uh
is is right in your face if you really
uh work with the computer
so i i have to illustrate what i'm
saying here
in in a couple of important examples
okay so so let's have a look at this
elementary problem which every primary
school student who has done
some fractions we'll know so if one-half
plus one-third plus one-fifth if i
evaluate that i get 31 over 30.
and
we can accept that
you know
a primary school student who's learning
fractions ought to be able to make this
calculation
now suppose that i
i want to demonstrate you know real
number arithmetic
which involves
things like x e x plus 7 or cosine of 5
or or the square root of 11 or something
like that if i try to uh well my
favorite example which i'm always
telling people is is this one here so i
should
for consistency write it down what is pi
plus e plus square root of two
okay so my computer is pretty smart and
if i ask it to to calculate this
just to evaluate it you see what it
gives me it gives me the same thing back
again
and this is not just because of this
program if you ask mathematica or pretty
well any other program you know to
calculate to do this arithmetic you're
going to get something similar
but it's not just this it like i could
do this in a a
myriad of different ways i could take
log 4 plus tan of 7 and i ask my
computer what is that
that's another example of you know of a
calculation or i could ask you know what
is
cosine of
3
times
you know sine of
seven
oh it doesn't know maybe
you have a problem with this because
i'm sure there's a way that you can get
it to do a decimal expansion oh yes i
can do that yes absolutely so i can
evaluate these things numerically
very easily so i can evaluate this
numerically i can evaluate all of these
numerically
and it's the numerical evaluation that
an applied mathematician is going to use
see
the
the applied mathematician only needs to
work to four or five decimal places
maybe if you're a theoretical physics
student maybe to 10 decimal places in
some strange
situations but typically to just a few
decimal places so
that's that's not a problem but
from a pure mathematics point of view
this idea that we have a valid
arithmetic of real numbers
is
it would seem contradicted here right
here i i'm i'm taking
very simple real numbers and i'm
performing very simple arithmetical
operations on them
and i'm not getting
any kind of calculations
the reality is my computer and almost
all
all computer programs that i know of are
incapable of doing real number
arithmetic
and you can frame that you know we have
various framings of real number
arithmetic in pure mathematics we talk
about dedicated cuts and we talk about
uh equivalence classes of cauchy
sequences um there's continued fractions
there's other ways it doesn't matter how
you frame it
their computational reality is always
the same that you can't actually compute
exactly
these operations on on on
relatively simple real numbers
what do people who are analysts
say to you in their response or their
objections
so
an analyst is going to be very
uncomfortable with this conversation
you see
before before jedican came along with
his theory of dedicated cuts
people knew about these problems uh a
lot because for centuries earlier people
had been making computations
with uh maybe i'll stop
sharing screens getting boring what is
it exactly that the analyst may
put to you as a rebuttal
yeah so most analysts are going to be
uncomfortable with this this train of
thought
because
historically long before dedican cut
theory came about in about the 1870s
the the working the working prototype of
a real number was an infinite decimal a
so-called infinite decimal
and
it's not too hard to to see that if you
want to have a theory of arithmetic with
infinite decimals
that's going to be problematic because
because the infinite nature of of the
decimals means that it's going to be
difficult or actually impossible to
prescribe
what the operations are
so for to be
so to be specific suppose that you're
given two computer programs that will
output the nth digit of two
decimals and you're asked to write a
another computer program that will
output the nth digit of the sum of those
two real numbers
you just said the nth digit of two
decimals you mean the nth digit of the
sum of two numbers or
yeah so let's say you you want to sort
of incorporate real number addition
on a computer in in a computational
fashion the inputs are two infinite
decimals given as programs
and your output is supposed to be
another program of the same kind which
represents the sum of those two things
so if you think about this for a little
while the way
kids are are taught
decimal number arithmetic in schools you
have two decimals to add them you start
on the right hand side
and you start on the right hand side and
and then the carries go to to the to the
left
and so then you pick up the carries as
you proceed from right to left
the problem is with if you have two
infinite decimals if you have in some
sense there's no right point to start
with right so what you have to do is you
have to typically sort of truncate and
then do some partial calculation
then go further truncate again do uh the
calculation again and then modify what
you've got
every time you go
but the problem with that is there's the
problem of carry of nines so at some
point you have you have the the
potential of getting a lot of nines so
that you're never in in possession of a
program that will guarantee that you've
got the nth decimal place
because
that nth decimal place could conceivably
depend on stuff that's happening very
very
far down down the track and you don't
know how far that's the critical thing
okay
so
at some level analysts would have been
aware that that
in terms of a theoretical number system
the infinite decimals don't really work
this is why this is why you the the 17th
century people 18th century people
didn't
create such a theory they would work
with decimals all the time
but they didn't have a theoretical
understanding of those and then they
they kind of avoided it because they
knew of these difficulties
so so the dedicant cut story the koshi
sequence uh equivalence class story
these are attempts by pure
mathematicians to kind of circumvent
um these difficulties would not face
them squarely on and surmount them but
to actually sort of circumvent them and
and and and uh
you know and make it look like like we
have an arithmetic of real numbers when
we actually we don't
we don't have a valid arithmetic of real
numbers that's just the way the world is
[Music]
and it's not because we're not smart
enough it's because we're attempting
something that's intrinsically
impossible what we end up having to do
is we have to then uh separate our
mathematics from from computational
reality we have to kind of go up you
know
and
go up on stilts so that we never touch
the floor you know we're walking around
on these stilts and and not looking down
just always looking up
um so
this means a a lack of contact with with
mathematical reality ultimately
and that manifests itself across i mean
i could talk for hours about these
manifolds varieties topological vector
spaces lead groups uh you know um
there's there's so many areas of
mathematics that um get
get disrupted by the the weakness of our
underlying numerical system that's the
so-called real numbers or the associated
uh complex numbers i think it'd be a
great time to give an example of a
problem that arises when one
doesn't take this computational view for
example in physics we use e
all the time
it's rare to find a formula without e so
what is the solution we just replace
this with something else is is physics
breaking down in some way now i know
with feynman path integrals you can
solve it by saying it's finite no no i
see i i i think you you
yeah you i think you physicists are are
fine because you're not thinking of this
e as an infinite decimal you're thinking
of e as
a
as a finite decimal of some variable uh
number of decimals which you can kind of
choose you can choose the amount of of a
resolution depending on the problem that
you have in mind
so you're playing along with with the
pure mathematician's notation because
you've gone to math class and you've
learned about e and so on but
effectively you're adopting an applied
mathematical point of view which doesn't
require the infinite decimals
you know and and you're actually working
in a numerical system
which is a an approximate decimal system
which is not the real number system it's
it's what the computers actually do you
know you have
some finite number of decimals and you
have to work with that and you have to
deal with truncations and round off and
and so on so right right right
now there's this physicist i'm not sure
if you've heard of him his name is
nicholas jison
have you heard of nicholas just i have
his argument against the reality of the
real numbers goes as follows i think
it's an argument more about discrete
space time though i don't know if that's
exactly the case if an electron carries
with it at space-time point it would
have to carry an infinite amount of data
to specify a certain real number and
thus it would create a black hole now i
don't know if i buy that argument per se
because it means that the electron
carries with its space-time point i'm
not sure what that means but for people
who feel like what you're saying is
radical in many ways some physicists
already are in line with this thinking i
think you're absolutely right and
you know the 20th century physics has
has um squarely acknowledged the the
the fact that our
our underlying space time is not
infinitely divisible
you see the cont the model of the
continuum is the real number uh the real
number line it really assumes uh an
essential infinite divisibility of of of
the line right that's the point and
you've got as many decimals as you want
so every time you add a decimal you're
dividing by 10. okay but physicists know
that
that's not the way the world is you you
get down to 10 to the minus 30 or
whatever and you had a planck scale and
then and then that divisibility just
erodes